when answer-the get calissa's to music
in his car he hears sounds from speakers
made by danish high-end manufacturer
dunno do sound quality that cost him
some twenty seven hundred euros car
buyers can also get a slimmed down
version for around six hundred euros
what's interesting is that i can really
tell the difference because i drive
other cars as well and the combination
of an especially quiet ride and this
full transparent sound that do now do
gives me is just like a special holiday
to me i drive long distances and it's
just more fun to drive this way dunno do
in the small town of scan dubois denmark
has been turning out loudspeakers for
German carmaker folks vlogging for over
10 years now much of the work is done by
hand the link to the automotive giant
has been a massive boon to the company
and it's 400 employees some 100 thousand
vehicles per year are rolling off the
line with do now do speakers installed
Janell diaz research and development
department pursues the best possible
sound quality while dispensing with
trendy effects like the booming bass we
have the philosophy of authentic
fidelity which means that we want to
reproduce what is put on the record
meaning that whatever source you play
you should hear the source and not
everything else more and more of the
world's car makers are collaborating
with high-end audio system makers as
more car buyers pay more for good sound
trade magazines estimate that about one
in four car buyers take advantage of the
option when offered
these speakers provide the benchmark for
the sound the Danish engineers aim for
in a car the small enclosed space of a
car presents a challenge and the
solution results in the far higher
prices
the space isn't the only obstacle to
perfect sound on wheels the systems have
to be light and compact and they have to
overcome loud background noise without
overwhelming listeners sitting close to
the speakers driving a car is very
dynamic you can drive a different speed
on highways and on in cities and you
actually have to let the the radio and
amplifier adapt to the environment
materials design positioning of the
speakers inside the car that's also what
needs to come together in an optimum
compromise once the acoustic engineers
have pinpointed the ideal balance for 12
high middle and low frequency speakers
in the car they start fine-tuning the
sound it has to form a harmonious whole
for every seat even with their
sophisticated equipment in the end the
engineers put their trust in their own
ears you have several tweeters placed
around the car you also have a subwoofer
and we are delaying the tweeters so and
the speakers so they arrive at the same
time at the position you are optimizing
the sound for so that the driver in the
car will actually feel like they have
sitting in the chair listening to which
is music like at home
high-end audio for the car thousands of
music fans are willing to pay extra for
the experience